well well well there's a different
energy in here tonight and you know why
Steve do you know why that there's a
different energy wiser different energy
steam episode number 50 of the
gentleman's dojo welcome back to me
gentlemen
over 50 there were a lot of people who
said we would not make it past the third
episode and i want to say we proved bill
byrne al Madrigal wrong they said that
it wouldn't last the dojo would have no
interest amongst friends and family yeah
but it is booming it was only until
episode 49 that all things comedy
started retweeting us that's true they
hadn't up until then yeah exactly yeah
this is big in fact we don't even use
their studio we're broadcasting from a
shell station on labrea lot of people
don't know that so episode 50
congratulations yeah yeah yeah I mean
it's been awesome but by the way we look
back on the first 49 if you had to pick
one episode just one what was your
favorite favorite yeah out of the gates
uh I gotta say your mom yeah I shouta
God she really want me with his studio
both yeah yeah she called Ana was
hilarious but when she was in studio it
was really hard heartwarming today
touching and I really and on top of that
she's just a great woman I really would
I also do love when she called in at the
second one we did the call-in show was a
huge success had almost four and a half
callers uh actually won't one was Brad
Williams so we had to call it I just
remember she's giving this soft
emotional plea that she was apologetic
and wanted your forgiveness for you know
making fun in this that and the other
thing in the two seconds later shes
bagging on you about the esquire show ya
wonder where she got it all from so I
that my mom obviously was one of my
favorites also are you cash levy still
one of my favorites cash was was yeah he
would be my top five pick up artist was
another great way yep yep yep yep boy
all of my guests huh I can't even think
of who you booked some hockey player um
but I like cash talking about the sneak
ends to every different event that he's
done well Theo Fleury was definitely
something I didn't really anticipate you
know I kind of knew I didn't realize how
open he would be in terms everything
that happened to him one who's come up
in the farm leaves in Canada right and
that by far was one of the most
impactful I think episodes we've done so
far but it was it was fun going back
from the from the very beginning
discovering it and figuring out what we
were trying to
oh and then it just became let's just
talk to people were interested in not
just strictly do stand ups but every now
and then if a stand-up is intriguing why
not talk to him for it is crazy because
what's interesting is you don't know yes
yes hello would you you don't realize
what you're gonna get until you reach
out right so I think one of our podcast
we both agreed was awesome that we never
thought could even be tackled was Howard
Warshaw with the ET game like yeah sorry
game over yeah you and I both watched
the movie literally week before I've
seen it a couple of times yeah and just
reaching out to him and him still
willing to talk about it and have an
interest in it and talk to us I mean you
just do I guess you realize that people
still want to talk or tell their story
and when we got him I thought that was a
big thing and yeah it was amazing to
that he is responsible for it literally
one of the greatest accomplishments with
yars revenge on Atari and its biggest
failure quote unquote an Atari and he
just had such a great healthy kind of
optimistic outlook on it all in
retrospect and moving forward in his
life and I think I don't know I found
him to be very inspiring I like to have
a Patricia Ward Kelly on yep talking
about all those stories about Gene Kelly
that was really really awesome yes he
was great or i could have talked to her
for another two or three hours she was
great she was great i also i mean i
think two of the last once we've done
have been my favorite right so Dan Laura
says I'll and damn was racist just great
and I loved Matt Iseman he was fantastic
such a humble nice loveable guy I love
Iseman and I love who we have on today
because this is yeah this is you I'm not
gonna I got it like you I'm not gonna
dump on I'm not gonna bag on you all the
time like you back on me but I will
write giving credit where credit is due
yeah you pulled off it's a big one yeah
yeah an amazing feat yeah yeah our small
little podcast but I love this guy who
doesn't honestly who truly doesn't
between comedians and the general gist
but you go ahead and well I gotta tell
from here he is on the line rate the
greatest he's on the line he's done it
all and he's joining us in adding our
show to his resume one of the most
respected comics working out there today
we love him and I can't believe that
he's joining us for episode 50
this is just I'm tingling with
excitement that he's coming on her show
how about a round of applause for Brian
Regan everybody this is awesome yeah how
you doing Brian episode episode 50 a lot
of people said we would make it past
episode 2 but we are showing people that
we are here and let me just say this
brian i know that you've done so many
great things in your career but as a
little boy did you ever expect to be on
a podcast with two guys that can't sell
more than 30 tickets do you ever think
that this would be to something for
yourself Jesus Christ you know they say
you got it you gotta shoot for the stars
stars and you might land somewhere in
between no man I'm honored to be on with
you guys it's very nice of you we love
you hate me and thank you very much I
gotta save just from a personal
perspective the first gig I ever got on
the road uh was Charlie good nights I
forget I forget what year it is I have
like a journal I could go back and like
literally look up the dates but I got to
literally MC the show for you and it was
it was the first of two back-to-back
weekends where I was doing the weekend
with you and then with amazing Johnathan
and there were two just amazing weekends
but it was my first kind of for Ray
leaving New York City and going out and
kind of experiencing the road and I
could not looking back in retrospect I
couldn't have found you couldn't wish a
better headliner to work with and not
only work with but to watch over and
over and over again over the course of
weekend and just I was blown away so I
cannot thank you for that experience in
upper end well gosh you're very kind yes
he's about me yesterday more work you
know an amazing Johnathan are like on
two opposite ends of the spectrum oh
yeah yeah yeah what a what a two week
swing I love his stuff man well but
that's interesting that those you mean
you work there for two weekends in a row
I got but yeah because in order for me
to leave New York and kind of make it
worth my while I guess my quote unquote
booking agent at the time booked me two
back-to-back weekends and I you know I
got to hang out there and Charlie good
nights for two weeks and it was yeah was
the pendulum definitely swung to the
left and to the right between those two
weekends it was def
a different experience um I do want to
ask you arm because we we don't take too
much of your time up I do want to ask
you what did stand-up mean to you when
you first got into it and what does it
mean to you currently to this current
current day well when I was in college
when I decided I wanted to be a comedian
it was interesting for me because it was
the first time where I felt you know
passionate where I was like hey man like
I really quickly want to do this I
didn't know anything about it you know I
just knew that it was you know fun to
make people laugh my friends and stuff
like that but when i hit on the idea of
being a stand-up comedian i thought this
is kind of an audacious thing if it's
the right word to uh to go after and I
was you know I had no idea if it would
work out or not but it was kind of
exciting to feel like I'm at least going
to try this yeah I said to myself I'm
gonna try it and I'm gonna try it and
it's like if I fail I fail and you know
I haven't succeeded yet but come on at
it maybe one of these days so I've you
know I've enjoyed it ever since I mean
is there is there a point where when do
you save yourself out you know of all
the years that you're doing stand-up
when do you say to yourself well I I've
actually made it like I feel like I
don't have to go back to doing a day job
comedy is one hundred percent now the
gig what was that moment for you where
you're like wow this is this is what I
get paid to do well there's different
moments that the club the cover i
started at i had to i work there i SAT
people this is at the comic strip in
fort lauderdale florida sister club to
the comic strip in New York the open one
in Fort Lauderdale that's where I
started I was a busboy dishwasher I took
reservations i SAT people I did all of
that and so they would let me go on at
the end of the night and so I did that
for a couple of years then I went out on
the road
and you know I'm playing like these
little weekend rooms or one nighters and
when it was like between shows and stuff
like that I would help I would help the
places bus the tables because that's
that that's what was in my bones you
know I felt weird just sitting there and
then finally somebody came up to me and
said you know it's nice to feel want to
do this but you just get in everybody's
way appreciate the gesture but you're
not helping it right can you just sit
out in the back and I said okay so i
just sat down and I remember like that
was the moment where it was like I guess
I'm just this I guess I guess I'm just a
comedian and it was a very weird moment
to go so I just tell jokes and when I'm
done I don't have to help clean up very
bizarre but like financially was there
that moment where you're like oh wow I'm
making enough doing this that I don't
have to worry about other things uh
that's always been like a a gradual
thing but i'll tell you like a weird
moment it was when i first got a manager
my manager is Rory rose garden who was
also you know ray Romano's manager and
Robert Kline's manager and so I was in
New York doing my thing this is after
the fort lauderdale thing I moved to New
York so Rory signs me and he gets me a
gig at some college prep school down in
New Jersey I don't remember the name of
the school i was living in new york and
i was still doing you know spots at the
improv and Dangerfield's and stuff like
that so he gets me a spot uh this gig
for a thousand dollars I had never I I
had never even dreamed of getting a
thousand dollars for a show so I took
the train down there I did the show and
it went well so I felt like okay wow
this feels pretty good I get back on the
train
and i'm heading back to New York and I'm
thinking I've got time to hop on stage
at the improv so I get back to New York
I hop on stage at the improv and after
the show they give me fifteen dollars
I'm not sure what my copies were both
gigs taxed you 1099 for both gigs well
Brian I mean you've just you've
accomplished so much in your career is
there a goal that use that that is still
out of reach that you're looking to
aspire or attain yes yes I I would love
for I would love to have an opportunity
to do a show I say a used to say a TV
show but now with the internet you know
a show even on the internet it's strong
I mean look at Seinfeld's comedians in
cars getting coffee yeah so there's
different platforms out there to do a
show but I would like to do I'd like a
shot at it you know uh uh like like you
had you know which was fantastic and I'm
very proud of you for thank you yeah
yeah I always think that anybody that
you know especially at the level you
gotta show that that is like being a
super bowl-winning quarterback you know
that no one will ever take that away
from you and it's uh it's a cool thing
just to have that little feather under
your cap well to keep it honest though I
was on TBS I was like winning the WNBA
championship to be honest when he Bryant
and this summer show and in fairness
Brian it was taken away it was take it
away after 33 episode so they call it
take the trophy away they did yeah you
want to show what you wanted to be
successful we understand I'll stay I'll
be
on behalf of you bribed oh man I mean
you know so i would just like you know
the planets to line up in a way where
some network or some group of people
would say hey do what you want to do but
it would have to be under that umbrella
too i mean i would i would want it to be
about how i think as a comedian and and
i need to be sitting down at the table
and saying hey let's do this let's do
that and if i can't get that then i'd
rather not even have a crack at it sort
of like what Ray Romano did right i mean
he was given the sitcom and he said
here's what i want to do this is how i
want to present it and they fought him
on it kind of almost like louis ck but
you you wanted to be your own thing and
not let the network's get involved right
correct and I know that that's you know
practically impossible especially the
bigger networks you know here's my
fantasy I want I want one network
meeting right I walk in and there's a
fat cat he sitting behind a desk he's
smoking a stogie and he says hey man I
like your kid go to a show and this is
the last you're gonna hear from please
don't bother me that guy walking around
on the set with his cigar going right no
maybe if you did this and maybe if you
did that oh no please please stay in
your office but it's interesting because
you talk about you know the level of
difficulty it is just to get a show
which absolutely which is crazy how
Steven I talk about people walking away
from a show and its successful but I
mean you're doing something that's so
unattainable for ninety-nine percent of
the comics in terms of working theaters
and you know I just saw you last time at
the dolby you know home of the Academy
Awards sold out Aaron Rodgers is there I
mean just when you walk out on that
stage in front of a sold-out dolby
theatre like what's going through your
mind i mean that has to be absolutely
crazy ah man i love everything about it
i'm very very fortunate you know
to be able to do this for a living you
know and and and to have gotten to a
point where a handful of people seem to
like it you know I love it and I never
get bored by it when I'm backstage
before a show any show you know I mean
like the Dolby in la is certainly like a
big thing but you know I could be an
Erie Pennsylvania greensboro north
carolina when I'm backstage I look out I
see a microphone i see a stool with a
bottle of water on it and hearing the
murmur of the crowd just gives me a warm
feeling every night I know it sounds
corny but I'm like how lucky am I you
know I just get to go out there and just
share some goofy thoughts with these
people and you know and they seem to
like it and they give me a handful of
dollars afterwards my pretty cool I
gotta ask you Brian because it seems
like it seems like stand-up has
definitely changed over the last 15
years definitely since I've been in
where prior to it seemed like you cut
your chops on the road and you really
were respected as a comic you look at
all those comedians in the in the 80s
that got those sitcoms they were really
known as like kind of Road dogs and now
is almost like to kind of camps it's
like Road comics and then there's like
the alternative comics that almost have
like a change stroker kind of elitist
vibe about themselves where they're all
going to the Ivy League schools and for
some reason other you you are somebody
that is absolutely respected amongst
both camps because any time you go into
like you go down to melt down or UCB or
you go down to the irvine improv or
hollywood improv or any of these clubs
that the road guys are working at and
coming off every time comics talk about
comics your name is revered what do you
think you're doing or if you had to
describe why do people love you so much
because I I'm one of those guys and it's
something we're all those elitist kind
of like snobby comics they still love
you as well you just you you kind of
like that guy that crosses all the
boundaries well first of all thanks man
it's very kind of you to say and I don't
know I'm always uncomfortable you know
feeling like I'm even close to patting
myself on the back you know it's like I
don't know I I'm part of me is like god
I just try to always be careful to not
try to figure out what the audience
wants and to not try to figure out what
comedians want right oh I always try to
always come back to what do I think is
funny what do I think is funny what do
and and and if people agree well then
great and that can be stay in my act you
know what I mean but I've always tried
to resist going what will this audience
laugh at but at the same time I try to
resist what would comedians look up to
what would comedians respect you know I
I try to be careful not to cater to
either one of those groups I'm just like
I'm like what do I think is funny and
and and that's one thing i do sometimes
when i'm onstage if a shows not going
great i get this goofy little thing i do
where I go hell with all these people
imagine me sitting out in the middle of
the audience and just make me laugh and
then once when I do that I feel like I'm
being true to what I'm trying to do that
right you know I I still might not get
them back you don't I mean but at least
I feel like I'm not selling out I'm not
chasing it I hate that feeling of
chasing after a crowd or more you know I
mean it's yeah it's an uncomfortable
feeling so if I hear you correctly Brian
you're saying you're the anti orny Adams
I don't even know what that means so
what does that mean what it means is
brian is loved by everybody but he's
selfish it's all about him what makes me
me very self know the best don't know
yeah I like it say I do have a really
good show and I walk off stage people go
nice set they really like you I say I
don't give a [ __ ] about them
haha where's that money don't look at me
where's the guy with a cigar book book
but wait Liz there's no possible way
that if you have a theater full of fans
right that are rapidly there to see you
that I'm sure that there's never times
now that you're not just crushing every
theater correct and you're gonna be
modest in your answer but I know that
the answer is you're not due yet I'm
saying not do you mean like uh no III
not shows where I I continued to
experiment play around you don't I mean
so it's like I'm gonna have you know
shows I mean I'm always trying to get
the job done when I'm on stage but right
same time I'm always trying to add new
stuff and let stuff fall by the wayside
and uh you know new stuff you don't know
what's going to happen with it you know
and if you're not willing to you know
try new things you're never going to
continue I think that's one of the
reasons why I've been fortunate enough
to have a following is when people come
out to see me I'd like to feel like
they're if they saw me two years before
they're gonna see a bunch of stuff they
didn't see last time right you know and
you know I like that compliment as much
as you know if somebody comes up to say
man I thought you were funny tonight
certainly that feels good but i also
like when people come up and say man we
saw you a year or two years ago most of
the stuff you did tonight we never heard
before I that I like that compliment
just as much well I ever said that to me
I've been doing the same accidents 83 I
will say this I I used to work at prior
to even you know my first job out of
college was at carolines comedy club I
had never been to a stand-up show before
and because i was working at the club i
was introduced to stand up and was
entranced by it and wanted to pursue it
but i remember you coming in there and I
brought my parent I was absolutely blow
I know anything about stand-up and you
came in you were headlining and I was
just blown away and I brought my parents
back the next night and I was like you
got to see this guy and we came and I'd
watched your show than I
before and I'm watching with my parents
and the first 30 minutes was completely
a different 30 minutes and I was just I
was talking to staff and I like dizzy
always and it you were just mixing it up
the whole time but was it was
unbelievable that you have that plethora
of material but I do want to ask you
this you know look I think like comedy
at in some ways rooted in failure
because it's a trial and error to trial
and error but then also there's the
peaks and valleys of of the career
itself what to you was the biggest
failure to yourself arm over the course
year career and then what did you how
did you come out and break into the
light and and take away from it what did
you learn from it I've had some excuse
me I've had some you know pretty
devastating crushes like- crushes you
know um where you think wow this might
be the thing and it goes away there it
doesn't happen and one of those
experiences for me was when i was living
in new york city and do you remember
Rodney Dangerfield's young comedian
special oh yeah well you know and that
that would that broke comedians I mean
like you know people who you never heard
of would get on that show and boom they
were a star because of it you know it
was a huge huge thing to get on well I
wasn't even on the audition for that I
was emceeing the audition for it at
Dangerfield's in New York City and and
if you ever emceed at Dangerfield's they
would make the MC go on at the end when
the checks dropped and each X for 15
minutes yes so so I'm not even like
thinking that they're looking at me you
know that they weren't there for me I
was bringing up all of the auditioners
to try to end Rodney Dangerfield's in
the back the HBO people were in the back
and they were watching the auditioners
and then the checks hit and then I gotta
go up there and eat for 15 you know yeah
15 minutes but but I had figured out a
way to be funny and self-deprecating
because I done it a lot of times and
then the sets over and I'm getting ready
to leave and then somebody comes up to
me and said
the Rodney Dangerfield in the HBO people
are interested in you for the comedian
special young comedian special and I'm
like I wasn't even on the audition you
know yeah and they were like well we did
they were watching you the whole night
and like what you were doing but they
know that it was unfair for you to do
the check spot so they'd like for you to
come in tomorrow night and do a set and
they want to watch you specifically so I
was like damn so I came in the next
night and it was like God you know
wednesday or thursday you know i mean it
was like 20 people in the audience
unified people in the audience Rodney
Dangerfield in the back a couple of HBO
people in the back I don't have to warm
up they have an MC MC goes up does this
thing brings me up it's a dead crowd and
I go up and die Oh God died yeah nothing
nothing I just like you know and I walk
offstage after a 15 minute 20 minute set
and went out to the bar I don't even
know what I don't even know what to do I
was like embarrassed to walk by the
taste I mean you know I don't want to
put them on the spot of not having to
take icon yeah so I I just walked out to
the bar like got numb you know that
feeling of well what geike what just
happened yeah and then Rodney
Dangerfield walked out and said hey you
know i just well you know it's not up to
me it is a group that makes the
decisions you know so I I'm like alright
no problem and I just I want to thank
you for the opportunity I just really
really appreciate the opportunity and
then I walked out I didn't get the show
but it was crushing for me at the time
you know cuz that's the time when you
have those moments you think this is the
moment this is it right and when it
doesn't happen you don't have the luxury
of getting in a time time travel machine
and going 15 years ahead and going oh no
everything's gonna be okay why you think
it you think that's it and so it was it
hurt for for a couple months until you
know something else came around a corner
is that that's so crazy well if it's any
consolation Steve didn't make it on a
comics unleashed over the eight seasons
they did he was all right
thank you you know Steve knows Steve
knows um we were wondering that this is
this is a question we're so interested
in you when when you work clubs
obviously there were certain things when
you started headlining that would
frustrate you because things weren't
done the right way and the staff you
know hadn't prepped the club up the
right way and now that you're at this
completely different level you're
working theatres you're working these
amazing spots is there something that
frustrates you when you work these great
amazing venues that just doesn't get
done or you know you walk in and
something isn't right is there because
I'm sure that you still experience
something but what what would that be um
well I mean you know there are things
that can be troublesome I have a great
tour manager and he's pretty on top of
everything you know I mean so but you
know things are gonna fall through the
cracks I I have and this I'm sure isn't
unique to me but it bothers me when
somebody in the very front row is
holding the iphone up at you and not
even trying to be discreet about it you
don't I mean because I'm it isn't so
much that they're filming me is that
other people around or watching the guy
Phil me and it's like a distraction and
I'm not good at switching gears and once
I have to put the disciplinarian hat on
just for even a second it completely you
know changes the mood and the tone of
what i'm trying to do up there you know
what I mean yeah like and it's very hard
to go hey put your stupid phone away
stupid stupid idiot and then go by way
to do sprinkles are gonna bother you but
you do you have to go do you have to
become the sheriff or a few seconds
because there's no security in the
audience you're yelling take good touch
it with the sheriff the head John
I'm no good at this back to the comedy
I'm gonna just be a sheriff put the
phone away take luck videotape me right
in front of my face O'Brien we're
nearing the finish line we do something
every now and then with with guys and
gals that we really love and it is a
segment we call how good does Wikipedia
know Brian Regan so we can do this with
you real quick according to wikipedia
your first television appearance was
what am I supposed to say you're
supposed to answer you not sure you jump
it Gary's filming with an iphone right
now I don't know what I don't know what
it says um entity my first TV appearance
on a national level was MTV half-hour
comedy hour ooh wikipedia I I guess got
it wrong it's saying the Pat Sajak show
in 1989 well they're wrong they're wrong
okay wikipedia you messed up Pat Sajak
number of times you've appeared on Pat
Sajak but it wasn't the first thing that
I was okay uh number two the number of
times you appeared on the David
Letterman program i believe it was 28
bingo that is astounding by the way yeah
yeah i was gonna ask only one ely thank
you i was really good i was gonna estes
really really quickly yeah what point
Brian because obviously you did the show
so many times at what point does the
Booker just leave you alone that you go
in there you know what set you're gonna
do they just leave you be and you don't
have to run it for eight people five
times the night before they that
happened yes probably you know not about
the 12th or 13th maybe you know um where
they just started trusting that they'd
like that I knew what they wanted and
you know I I still always submitted to
set you know they had different things
that happened over the years but
sometimes like when Eddie Brill was
doing it you know I would just do the
set over the phone for him you know me
but then when he was no longer there
I would just script it out and just send
it in um rarely did they ever question
it or whatever you know I think I look
at my stuff in print and I'm big
sometimes it doesn't look very funny
they're gonna probably read this and go
we gotta cancel immediately they're
gonna send you a pat sajak the whole
thing I'm setting is you know Brian
hunches over crosses eyes and makes loud
noises well Brian we cannot stay a
minute we better bucket before somebody
else gets it why we cannot we don't want
to take too much time because we know
your your call in and we like from both
of us we love you so much and there's
you know we'll probably speak on behalf
of every comic that we even know and for
our friends with we love you and I pray
to God that you get that show as well
because I'll be the first to be in line
or get a ticket or work on it tune in to
watch Brian well we love you man thank
you my pet would you have 49 followers
on Twitter Stephen I want to be added we
want to be that guy no no ah but we
really I mean I just saw your latest
Fallon I mean so funny just that the
great joke about the other team said
that you guys were great sports that
they were you know they really I mean
that joke about they give us a lot of
luck or the joke was what was either Joe
let him do it you do a brown oh the UH
give him a lot of credit a lot of credit
you got to give the team a lot of credit
I would have been here sooner but my
face was covered in champagne and
balloons streamers it's such a great job
laughing at my own joke but you but you
could tell like when you were on Fallon
you paneled for a couple seconds like
Fallon just was all over you just
genuinely a huge huge fan and that just
that's got to mean so much because
you've done all the late night shows I
mean but people adore you and it is
honestly true uh you cannot find anyone
that doesn't put you in their top three
yeah favorite comics it's impossible you
just can't find anybody I I'm blown away
by the huge compliments you guys are
just absolutely true yeah absolutely
true well thank you my friend keep
killing it uh we look forward to seeing
at some point on the on the tube on the
big screen and we love you man thank you
so much Brian Regan that's very kind you
guys have a great rest of your day man
thank you thanks Brian thank you right
back the best episode 50 right there the
best I am just still like and it really
is it's so true you're never gonna find
somebody who does not put him in their
top three favorites always always always
you know is so many times like when we
traveled with the Sullivans on tour you
know every now and then you have that
conversation where you just say who your
top three comics they you love listening
to now who'd you grow up with and it's
just like it's he is across the board
guys love him and by the way urban
comics love Brian Regan is yeah yeah um
he really is just I mean and I remember
seeing at the dolby sold out sitting
right in front of us was Aaron Rodgers
yeah and Olivia Munn you're like well
these guys are fans I mean it's just
like he is just a real deal and I
couldn't ask for a better guest for our
50th episode here on the gentleman's
dojo all things comedy what a great way
to wrap up episode 50 I was episode 50
crazy in the can crazy um where can I
find you can a comedy come on seriously
really what is it I love this on from
500 days of summer okay ah that's fever
and live we cannot thank you guys enough
for listening the past 50 episodes I
think we get to a hundred than we quit
by the way no this weekend we will be at
stand up live in Phoenix standable out
of phoenix on brea improv chicago improv
a lot of dates coming up follow us any
order tickets available torso
go we love you guys thanks Brian